كما تشرق الشمس على منحدرات دوفر البيضاء ،
وكذلك سخط
سائقي الشاحنات العالقين على الحدود ،
فأنتم أغبياء ، أيها الناس الأغبياء ،
ينتظر الآلاف منهم العودة إلى
أوروبا القارية ،
ولا توجد حمامات ولا مراحيض
، ومحطة وقود واحدة ، ويغلقون
المرحاض
لماذا قريبون
لماذا أغلق المرحاض يلقي باللوم على نوع جديد
من فيروس كورونا
، صعدت الحكومة البريطانية من
إغلاقها ، حيث تولى الفرنسيون زمام المبادرة بإغلاق الحدود مؤقتًا ، وهذا
ما شاهدناه يحدث
طوال اليوم التوترات بين
سائقي الشاحنات الذين تقطعت بهم السبل ومواجهة الشرطة
و  الصراخ والصراخ ، لكن
الأمر لا يتعلق فقط بصحة
هؤلاء السائقين وسلامتهم ، بل يتعلق
بالوظيفة الحاسمة التي يقومون بها للحفاظ على
طريق الإمداد الحيوي هذا مفتوحًا بين المملكة المتحدة
وأوروبا القارية ، وهو ما يجعل بريطانيا
تشعر
بالعزلة تمامًا
رسميًا ، فالحدود مفتوحة لسائقي الشاحنات الذين يعانون من
آثار سلبية.  نتيجة الاختبار من 72
ساعة الماضية
ولكن الأمر سيستغرق عدة أيام لمسح الأعمال
المتراكمة
ولهذا السبب يتوقع أكثر من أربعة  والشاحنات المتوقفة على مدرج مطار محلي على طول الطريق السريع ، هذا ما أشعر به ، نعم ، ليس جيدًا ، نعم ، إن المنظر بين سائقي الشاحنات يتجاوز جميع حواجز اللغة ، حيث أعلن برنامج الاختبار يوم الثلاثاء أنه لم يكن موجودًا في أي مكان لجزء كبير من اليوم الليلة الماضية عندما أتينا إلى هنا حيث قال رجال الشرطة والشرطة إننا نحاول الاتصال بالإنترنت ونحاول طوال الوقت ولا يوجد اختبار مناسب لإنجلترا الذي جربته عبر الإنترنت ولا يمكنك أن تنسى الاختبار كلما طال انتظاره مع القليل من الصرف الصحي كلما كان ذلك أكبر تؤدي المخاطر الناتجة عن جائحة الإحباط إلى استياء من كل من السائقين والشرطة أخيرًا وصلت وحدة اختبار مع حلول الغسق وانتهى اليوم حيث بدأ مع توترات شديدة وهم هنا يحاولون بقلق شديد العودة إلى المنزل في عيد الميلاد والآخرين في طريقهم. ابعد عنها سلمى دوزيس cnn دوفر انجلترا